when i was a kid i had a crush on a girl
named zoe she and i were friends from
preschool all the way through high
school but in elementary and middle
school
i was smitten i never told her though i
suspect
i wasn't that subtle about it i'm not
good at this kind of stuff but now
i'm 26 years old and i'm single so i'm
gonna ask her out
hello hi zoe hey dakota
sorry this is weird i had a crush on you
in elementary school and middle school
and i was wondering if you would want to
go on a date with me
oh yeah sure are you free at all this
week
i'm free on thursday yeah thursday
thursday should work let's do thursday
the date was set
so now i had to prep everything to make
sure it was the best it could be
so i decided to start the date off here
at our elementary school that zoe and i
both went to i figured it'd be kind of
fun to
to meet here kind of where i first
had a little crush i haven't seen zoe
since like high school really so it's
been
eight years now i truly like don't know
what she's up to or what she's doing if
it goes well i think
at the end maybe i will see if if she
wants to
go out on a real date without cameras
kind of nervous about that though
zoe and i grew up really good friends
but after high school i moved to new
york for college
and as with many high school friends we
drifted apart so i was excited to get to
see her and reconnect
pretty soon she arrived she is here
hello oh my god hi hi
hi it's really good to see you too
it's been a while so pretty here i kind
of forgot how nice it is
this playground has changed a lot it
seems more tame
you can't really get the injuries that
we used to get i missed that
yeah remember rocket day here yes so i
was just thinking about
i think my rocket got lost in the woods
see mine completely fell apart
i was so bummed i'm sorry so do you have
any idea what's happening today
no i have no idea what's happening you
won't tell me anything no
that's the fun of it i'm nervous so what
are we doing
i'm not telling you we're just gonna go
to there and then you'll see
should i jump one yeah two
oh god and i'm scared three
oh oh are you okay
yeah are you okay i stuck it initially
yeah you did
and then you fell it was time to head
out but we couldn't get there
any old way so to properly capture the
middle school date experience
i'd rented a minivan and hired a special
driver oh hi laura
i figured it'd be fun to be driven to a
date like we were in middle school
i was a little nervous about how the
date was gonna go but as we sat in the
car the conversation
and the memories started flowing
remember jerry the old bus driver used
to live down there yeah i used to buy my
maple syrup from him
my mom would give me money and i would
get on the bus and give him money and he
would hand me a gallon of maple syrup
on the school bus and soon enough we are
at our next stop
okay are we going on a boat yeah yes
it's a nice awesome it's beautiful this
is gonna be so fun
all right let's hop this fence yeah
don't follow me i'm not gonna risk it
bye mom bye laura kind of forget
like in the winter how nice this summer
is here nothing like a boat on like
champlain i know i've been on a boat in
a
long time during kindergarten zoe's
family went back to england for a few
years
and when she returned to school i
immediately had a crush
and so did my best friend kyle we spent
many sleepovers arguing over who got to
like her
[Music]
then things started to get a bit wet
okay
that's fine i'll survive i'm not heading
around white shirt
oh my god i almost did
pretty soon though we had arrived where
are we
an island an island thanks dakota
welcome
thank you our private island wow it's
beautiful
i haven't really seen you since after
high school yeah yeah like a couple
times
but now like one little path into the
woods the most dangerous game you're
just gonna hunt me at some point well
i'm gonna start scoping out places then
to hide maybe grab some weapons so i
studied athletic training and then now i
work
out of high school as an athletic
trainer are you like the cool teacher
no no definitely not why not because i'm
not cool
yeah you are and when you're nyu for
film now i make youtube videos for a
living you're doing a good job though
it's so fun to watch thank you
so we are here wow at this pure
tower oh my god do you want to go up
yeah
we climbed up the fire tower to get a
better view of the island and the beauty
of lake champlain
[Music]
from this vantage we could also see the
next stop on our date you see that field
over there
yeah we're gonna go over to that field
because
i have something prepared okay i like
how you're just going along with this
this looks so good we're having a picnic
um
but i forgot the blanket that's okay so
we're gonna sit on a rock
perfect this looks amazing dakota should
we pop the champagne
i guess so or should we start with the
wine
this is a screw top it's easier perfect
good call
so are you planning on staying in new
york forever i don't know
i'm actually considering moving to
london next year that's awesome you're
gonna move out west maybe
like i'm hoping at some point i mean
i've always wanted to go
and my sisters out there and as much as
i love it here
it's i feel like where i'd want to be
when i'm older
so i feel like i want to leave for a
little bit okay this strawberry is
perfect
yeah that looks so good i already have a
piece of bread in my wine
that's okay that's part of the aesthetic
yeah i'm eating both anyway
so how old were you when you came back
from england was that third grade fourth
grade
it was yeah the summer before fourth
grade i think it was 10.
obviously i already knew you yeah we
knew each other from preschool
but then i was gone and we didn't see
each other for a while
so sad when you came back i was like oh
my god
this little ginger girl with a british
accent only because i had an accent it
was all the accent
like i see it with my mom all the time
people are blinded by an english accent
it's true and i'm so mad i don't have
mine anymore because
i would be so much more successful like
i would have gone
so much farther in life you should just
fake it i wish i could
not do it no kyle and i both had crushes
on you
in elementary school i didn't know that
kyle has told me multiple times oh of
course he has but i didn't know that you
ever did oh yeah i did
oh well dakota we all had crushes on
youtube
really yeah wait when elementary school
i remember
for sure shelby and sarah too oh no goat
shoes down i'm an oblivious person
i do remember one time we were it was
like middle school i think
i was riding on the home on the bus i
don't know why this memory is vivid in
my brain
and colton like screamed at us like zoe
dakota you guys should date
i probably just turned beat right
absolutely it was like a traumatizing
experience yeah
i think that's why it sticks with you
still remember oh yeah i do
that's the weird thing is like as a
child your like emotions feel
so strong and they also feel like life
or death like
now i have like feelings for someone and
i'm like
oh that'll be nice we're not yeah it's
fine and i wonder if it's because you
have so much
other stuff going on with your life if i
had a crush on someone i was
obsessed with them yeah i mean my
friends would have
like a nickname for them who do you have
crushes on
other than me of course i mean pretty
much every
carter luke oh yeah of course kyle and
fitzy when i lost the accent was it done
for you
absolutely no no i don't think so jesus
that scared me oh my gosh that was mine
on myself
oh my god that's awful it's all foam
that's okay cheers cheers to our
childhood
if you did not know me
the slightest you encountered me say out
and about
would you have said yes to a date like
if we were like at a bar or something
and i was getting to know you
yeah yeah you're fun you're really nice
wow oh my god i'm just i actually made
this video to be complimented a lot
well here i am i would probably
say yes to you if you talk to me now
yeah but i don't have the accent anymore
i know and so how can i like you it's
impossible it's kind of gone
i've moved on to karen things were going
really well and zoe and i continued to
talk late into the afternoon
but eventually it was time for her to go
what a cool date you did elaborate then
most of the time
yeah i will say i don't i usually do
this
okay well good to know i actually have
to one up myself yeah every time next
time
in that moment time froze as i prepared
to ask the question i've been thinking
about
all day would you my kids want to go on
another one at some point
yeah that would be fun okay do it i
would love that okay
cool well i'll see you yeah bye bye
success i'd fulfilled my childhood
dreams and as i watched zoe drive away
on the boat i looked forward to seeing
her again
that went well i'm really excited
for maybe the second date especially for
doing it without
a camera
[Music]
you